you believe in ghosts yeah definitely oh
damn but it makes me sad to think that
ghosts would still be on earth because
if you
are here and you don't go on to
somewhere better and you're trapped here
how long
can you and if other ghosts are there
and you hear about people being like uh
ghosts in the house or haunted house if
they're trapped in that house loud
ghosts
yeah or they buy them are they is it is
it only bad spirits and then they're if
there's good ones are they is there
something in the in the middle or are
you trapped here and it's bad and you're
just like trapped here and then it makes
you think it makes me think this then
if ghosts are trapped here and that's a
punishment obviously because you don't
go somewhere good then then what are we
here if it's bad for them after
right is that for us what does that mean
yeah maybe we're ghosts maybe we're like
ghosts that people could see real well
like ghosts with blood in them
or something you know what i'm saying
like because yeah if you go
i guess if you
if you die right
and you suddenly you think cause you
probably all at that point if you read
prepared to die
you know
then you're like all right you got your
fingers crossed you know
that's that roshambo with the lord you
about to see what the deal is
and then you just suddenly just a damn
ghost now you're invisible but still
hanging around in the same neighborhood
you gotta i guess at that point then
what do you do
that's where it gets scary because if
then because if there's ghosts and then
it's like like i was saying like how
long are you there right by yourself and
if can you see
other ghosts other ghosts they got it
you have to be able to see other ghosts
i can't imagine you just sitting around
as being a ghost
and you can't even
talk to the other ghosts yeah
come on man don't be like that bro don't
make a world where if people did
they get nobody else to talk to unless
that's their punishment or is it or or
is it a choice and they choose not to go
on because they
they're
unfinished business i'm gonna stay in my
house
yeah my house hoa [ __ ]
i paid the hoa fees for this for the
real baby yeah
yeah i'm staying here boy
i'd have paid up yeah what if you pay
six months rent in advance run you'll
die in the first month in a flood or
something i got a solid five months left
[ __ ] i'm here
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one